well a woman and baby are safe tonight
after being held hostage in a northeast
valley apartment
metro telling us an armed man barricaded
all three of them
inside of an apartment near craig and
las vegas boulevard
that's where we find joe muller tonight
with the latest on exactly what happened
the good news this evening is that
there's no injuries reported in this
incident
police say around 7 15 this evening that
suspect came outside of that apartment
and people who live in this apartment
complex are happy they're able to go
back home
you don't want to see anybody get hurt
police lights and worried neighbors
filled the area around craig road in las
vegas boulevard wednesday
i got kids of my own i have two a girl
and a boy so i already know what's
probably going through her brain i feel
bad it was a hectic day in and around
the eagle traits apartment complex metro
says a man held a woman and a child
hostage at gunpoint i'm overwhelmed and
i'm not even in there
and i can't even imagine what she's
going through the situation started at
around 1 30 in the afternoon
lvmpd dispatch received a call from a
citizen
informing us there was a female and an
infant who had a firearm pointed at them
by a male known to the female for nearly
seven hours negotiators and
investigators came in and out of the
apartment complex it wasn't until 7 15
when the suspects
gave up and came out something neighbors
were relieved to hear
but i'm just going to pray that
everything works out
as far as charges metro says they have
to go through that apartment to see what
sort of charges
the suspect might face reporting in the
northeast valley joe mohler 8 news now